The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: And let us start.
So let me again start
by reminding you
what we did before.
So consider, say, we have
a scalar field in AdS
So let me just summarize
what we did before.
So consider, say,
a scalar field,
phi, in AdS and with mass
times square, so with mass
squared given by m
squared, then we know,
when you go to the
boundary of AdS-- so let's
take z goes to 0--
then phi will have
the following
asymptotic behavior.
So these are the two independent
modes of phi [? to ?] infinity.
Of course, there are higher
order corrections in z.
And this delta is
given by 1/2 d plus nu.
And nu is given by
this square divided
by 4 plus m squared r squared.
So this is the behavior.
And so this phi is assumed to
be dual to some boundary, scalar
operator.
And then all of
those quantities,
on the gravity side, they
all have counterparts
on field theory side.
For example, the delta,
which, essentially,
is a function of mass,
then, essentially, it's
the scaling dimension of O.
It's a scaling dimension of O.
And this Ax
essentially translates
into the source for phi.
Or you can consider the
momentum space version, say, you
can do Fourier transform,
Ak, then go to the phi k.
And then we also showed, last
time, that the 2 nu times Bx
is actually related to the
expectation value of O.
And again, there's a
momentum space version of it.
So you can just
Fourier transform, then
become O k and Bk.
And in particular,
in the example,
we can see the
scalar field example.
In particular, in the
example, you can see that.
So we derived this relation
from a free scalar field.
but you can actually show this
relation is actually generally
true at non-linear level.
So if you also include the high
orders, et cetera, so including
non-linear dependence on
phi, actually this relation
remains true.
But due to the time, we
will not go into that.
The proof is actually
not very difficult.
So you can see that the
free scalar examples--
so, in the example, we
can see that actually
the B-- so in momentum
space, the B is actually
proportional to A. If you
remember what we did last time.
So in other words,
this one-point
function-- so B is related
to the one-point function.
So in other words,
the one-point function
it's proportional to the source.
So this is the standard story.
Say all x equal to 0
when phi equal to 0.
So if you don't have the source,
then this one-point function
is 0.
So you don't have a spontaneous
expectation value for the O.
And now the fact that
B is proportional to A,
so this is just reflects that,
in the presence of the source,
then, of course, the
expectation value-- so
let me write it in momentum
space for simplicity.
Then we're no
longer [INAUDIBLE].
Assume the source is small, then
you can expand the expectation
value in power series of phi.
So to the 0, so that
would be phi, and then
phi squared, et cetera.
So at linearized
level, say we just find
O k is proportional to phi k.
We just find that O k is
proportional to phi k.
And the proportional
constant is, in fact,
the two-point function.
So at linear level, so O k would
be just proportional to phi k,
but the proportional constant
is just the two-point function.
So the reason is very simple.
First, let me write
down the definition
of this two-point function.
So GEx in coordinate
space is defined
to be O x of 0, because
of translational symmetry,
so I can put the
other point to be 0.
So this is only the
function of one variable, x.
And then you can
Fourier transform,
and then you get GEk.
So this is how we
define the GEk.
So to see that this
is true, you need
to remember that
the GEk is given
from taking the generating
functional, delta phi k
and delta phi minus k, then
you set phi equal to 0.
So this is the definition
of the two-point function.
And then next, you can see
that the [? one  derivative ?]
of phi minus k-- so you can see
that this takes 1 derivative
on phi minus k.
That just gives you
the one-point function
in the presence of phi
and then delta phi k.
And take phi equal to 0.
So I just evaluated
this derivative.
So if you take this
generating functional,
take one derivative, we
just get one-point function.
And then this is the
other point function.
Then at the linear
level-- so if O k
is linear in phi k, of
course, taking the derivative
is just the same as dividing it.
So this is the same.
So continue over.
This is the same just as to
the phi k divided by phi k
at the linearized level.
And then so this tells you
that this pre-factor is just
the two-point function.
And so we can now write a
two-point function explicitly
in terms of B and A,
so this is just given,
because this is 2 nu Bk.
So this is just given by that.
So this is just a quick
summary of what we
did at the end of last lecture.
So that's how you can find
the two-point function.
So you work out what
B is, what the A is,
and then the rest of them
is the two-point function.
And the way we work out the
B and A is the following.
So at the linearized level, when
you solve the equation motion
for phi, then you impose
the boundary conditions
at infinity, A should
be equal to phi.
But then there's
another condition
being proposed to make
sure the phi is actually
regular in the interior.
So the regularity
condition, there's still
a relation between
A and B. And then
that leads to this
two-point function.
Any questions on this?
Is everything clear?
Good.
So now let's consider the
higher-point functions.
So this is, in principle,
straightforward to do.
Because, recall, that the
log CFT phi, this generating
functional, in the
field theory, is just
given by the classical
action on the gravity
side, which is the boundary
condition given by phi.
You're solving the
classical equation
motion, the initial action.
Then you just, as
we did earlier,
you just solve the
equation motion for phi
to the [? linear ?] order.
And then you validated
the initial action.
Then you can express,
for example, this SE
in power series of phi.
And then the quotient for
the power series of this phi
then just gives you
correlation functions.
So the principle of this
is straightforward to do.
We know how to solve the
classical equation motion.
We know how to plug
back into the action,
and then you are done.
So just to be able
to be more specific,
let's consider an example.
Let's just consider
two examples.
Again, let we just
consider the scalar field.
Now, I add the linear term.
For illustration, let me
give you two examples.
And so a very important thing is
that in our set-up, the lambda,
this cubic quotient is
proportional to kappa.
And then if you translate
into the field series side,
this is 1/n.
So remember, for anything
in the gravity action,
you always have the 1
over kappa squared, 1
over G Newton before
[INAUDIBLE] action.
And then when we try to
change phi into canonical
normalized, and then
you rescale phi.
And the consequence is that
this cubic term or quartic term,
then they will have quotients
proportionate to kappa.
And according to this rule, if
you have a quartic term, then
that will be proportional
to kappa squared, et cetera.
And so the key is that as
far as [? phi is ?] order 1,
then you can actually treat
those higher-order terms
by perturbation because
the quotient is small.
And of course, you can
also consider the situation
in which phi is
large, and then you
have to solve the full
nonlinear problem.
Then you cannot do a
perturbative expansion.
You have to do the problem.
So for our purpose,
if you want to find
the higher-point
function for phi,
then you need to
solve this equation.
So box phi is just
a Laplace operator.
I just save time.
So you need to
solve this equation.
And with the boundary condition
still the boundary condition,
the boundary value of capital
phi to equal to this phi x.
And let me call
this equation star.
So as I said, because
this lambda is small,
you can actually try to
solve this equation just
perturbatively in lambda.
And essentially, you're solving
it perturbatively in this phi,
because everything, in the end,
will be expressed in this phi.
So one can solve
star perturbatively
in phi, which is the
boundary value of the field.
And say phi c, you can expand it
as phi 1 plus phi 2, et cetera,
so the classical
solution expanded.
And this linear in phi.
And this is quadratic
in phi-- and et cetera.
And then when you plug
back this into the action,
then you find on
the initial action
can also be expanded in
power series of this phi.
So you will have S2 phi plus--
started with quadratic order--
and 3 phi, et cetera.
And then the quotient here gives
you the two-point function.
And then quotient here gives
you the three-point function.
And the quotient here gives a
four-point function, et cetera.
I hope the procedure is clear.
Any questions regarding this?
So even though this is
very straightforward
to do, conceptually,
but in practice
that it not what we would do,
because this is a very tedious.
It's very tedious.
And our knowledge of
quantum field theory
gives us something much
simpler to deal with.
Because this, essentially,
if you think about it,
is not very different from
doing a correlation function
calculation, just in the
flat-space quantum field
theory.
And there, whey you
calculate the Green function
in flat-space-- in
flat-space quantum field
theory, what do you do?
Do we try to solve the classical
equation motion and you iterate
the equation?
What do you do?
AUDIENCE: Draw a diagram.
HONG LIU: Yeah, you
use Feynman diagrams.
So here, it's exactly
the same thing.
So here it's much easier if you
just do the Feynman diagrams.
So let me first remind you
what we do in the flat-space.
So let's now go to
the field theory
one, standard, ordinary
flat-space QFT.
So now let's consider the lambda
phi cubed theory in flat-space
Just the same theory now
using the flat-space.
Let me call this star-star.
So essentially, let's
just consider star-star
in flat-space, now in
flat Euclidean space.
So if we are given a
field theory like that,
so how would you calculate the
following correlation function?
Say, suppose I want to
calculate phi x1, phi xn.
So now this x1, xn, they're
just flat-space coordinates.
To distinguish them,
let me just call y1,
yn, just not to confuse
about the AdS coordinate.
So in flat-space
with y, y mu, OK?
In flat-space with
coordinate y mu.
So now suppose you want to
calculate the correlation
function for this.
What do you do?
So what do you do?
It's easy.
What you do is that this
theory has a propagator, G,
[? with ?] [? arrow ?]
propagator.
And also, this theory
have a interaction vertex,
which is controlled by lambda.
And then, when you calculate
such endpoint functions,
you just fix your endpoint.
So now remember, this is
slightly different than what
you would normally do
in field theory one,
because, here, we're
doing coordinate space
rather than momentum space.
In field theory one, you're more
used to doing momentum space.
So here what you do is that you
fix y1, y2 y3, extends to yn.
So this is essentially the
location of your insertion,
of your field insertion.
So essentially, imagine
there's a source there.
And then you just connect
all the extended points
by propagators and with these
kind of interaction vertices.
So for example, you can have
something like this, et cetera.
And this connects to
some boundary point,
some other point,
et cetera-- say y's.
And this also have lines.
We just draw all
possible diagrams,
and you calculate that diagram.
You calculate those diagrams,
and they give you this thing.
And essentially, the
diagrams automatically
give you the
iteration procedure.
So now, back to
AdS, essentially, we
can just do exactly
the same thing.
Just remind yourself
of the procedure
of calculating this and what
we are going to do here,
and you easily
convince yourself.
So it requires a couple
of minutes' thinking,
but we'll leave it to yourself.
Actually, that procedure is
no different from just doing
the calculation like this.
Of course, the
difference is that now we
are in the curved spacetime
rather than flat spacetime.
But there's another
major difference.
So here, the source all lies in
the interior of your spacetime,
where you inserted the operator.
But here, all the source, phi
x, they lie at the boundary.
That's, essentially,
the only difference.
So if I just schematically--
so this is AdS.
This is the boundary.
And essentially, all the points
are lying on the boundary,
like we have x1, x2.
So let's consider
four-point function.
Because each one of them is
labeled by the boundary point.
And then for the four-point
function, you just connect.
So you can connect
the diagram like this.
Again, you have
the vertices, which
is the [? cube ?] of vertices.
But your endpoint is all
lying on the boundary.
So this structure also
tells you, actually,
there's two types
of propagators.
Because one type of propagator
connects the two bulk points.
And then there's this
kind of propagator
which connects the bulk point
into the boundary points.
So this is the difference,
one major difference,
from the flat-space case.
So here, all the
propagators are the same.
So here, the difference
is now, you also
have propagators which come
from boundary to the bulk.
So in this case, there are
two kind of propagators.
Here, you have two
type of propagators.
So one type of propagator
is what we call
the bulk-to-bulk propagator.
Somehow this is going up and up.
OK, I lost some
blackboard space.
So this the complete
analog, this
is the precise counterpart
of the flat-space propagator.
So this connects two points,
z, x, z prime, x prime.
So I still use the
notation that z is the bulk
[INAUDIBLE] direction.
And the x is along the
boundary direction.
And this bulk-to-bulk will
satisfy the standard Laplace
equation just as in flat-space.
So this gives you
the delta function.
Let me just express it, z minus
z prime delta x minus x prime.
So this is a complete analog
of the standard flat-space
propagator.
It's just now in
Anti-de Sitter space.
So this is a counterpart in AdS
standard flat-space propagator.
So in particular,
so as a propagator,
this should be normalizable
in either z or z prime,
so when you take
them to the boundary.
So more explicitly, for
example, the z at z prime,
x prime, should scale as z
prime to the power delta, when
you take z prime goes to 0.
And of course, this
should also be regular.
We should not have singularities
as z goes to infinity.
They should also be regular.
So essentially, these
condition will precisely
define those propagators.
But the idea is we
also, because the source
lies on the boundary, because
of this boundary condition,
we also have so-called
boundary-to-bulk propagators.
Actually, the standard
in flat-space one,
it propagates the field from
one point to the other point.
So that's why there's
a delta function here.
So the standard story,
there's a delta function here.
And you propagate
the field starting
from this point to that point.
So this boundary-to-bulk
propagator normally is written
as k z,x, but the second
index only has x prime,
because this is when you take
the boundary point to a bulk
point.
A boundary point, of course,
there's no z anymore.
So z prime is 0 here.
You don't need to write it.
And this boundary-to-bulk
propagator,
again, should satisfy
the Laplace equation.
But now the key point is
that, on the right-hand side,
because there's no bulk
source, so the right-hand side
should be 0 rather than
the delta function.
So that delta function is
due to the bulk source.
But we have to make
sure this k have
the right
non-normalizable boundary
conditions, so you
have the right boundary
condition to the boundary.
So this when it approach to
the boundary, as z goes to 0,
should be like z d delta,
delta x minus x prime.
So the k satisfies the Laplace
equation without a source.
But when you take this
propagator to the boundary,
then it should give you the
non-normalizable boundary
conditions, because you
should approach a source.
And the delta
function is put here.
So if you write,
say, a bulk field,
which is sourced by some
boundary source, say k z, x,
x prime times phi x
prime, and then this
will have right
boundary condition
that the phi x, z goes
to z d minus delta phi x.
So this boundary-to-bulk
propagator
does not have a
source in the bulk
but does have a source
in the boundary,
non-normalizable
off in the boundary.
So now with this two
propagator, then the story
is just actually as
in the standard way
you obtain the Green functions.
It's just really no different.
So let me just summarize
what we have discussed.
The boundary
endpoint function can
be obtained by, essentially,
endpoint function of the phi
field in the gravity side--
let me write it here-- just
related to the endpoint
function of the gravity field
on the gravity side, with
all these points, x1, xn,
they're lying on the boundary.
This side is treated as
ordinary field theory.
Then compute this endpoint
function of your field
but just put the
field on the boundary.
And then that would just
give you the AdS correlation
functions.
Yeah, and then you just
need to distinguish
two types of propagators,
a bulk-to-bulk propagator
and bulk-to-boundary propagator.
So any questions regarding this?
AUDIENCE: Now, here,
[INAUDIBLE] d minus delta.
Right there, the G goes to
[? d ?] phi in the delta.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But why
aren't they different?
HONG LIU: It's because
this must have a source.
So the boundary-to-bulk
propagator--
you propagate the source,
from the boundary to the bulk,
so that means that field
must have the right boundary
condition.
So that's the reason for this.
We must have non-normalizable
boundary conditions.
And that propagator is just the
standard flat-space propagator.
Of course, it's
always normalizable.
And in the flat-space,
when you construct
a propagator, of
course, it's always
used in a normalizable
wave function.
AUDIENCE: This is
that's non-normalizable?
HONG LIU: No, this
is non-normalizable.
This is designed so that
you have the right boundary
condition.
So this is designed so
that you can propagate
just as in flat-space.
If you have phi at
this point, and then
you can propagate to the
other point by convolution.
And of course, when you write
down the bulk field phi,
in general, you only
construct them out
of the normalizable modes.
Any questions?
Good.
So now let me make some remarks.
So here, this
procedure of iterating
the classical
equation of motion,
solving the classical
then iterating the
action, of course,
again, from our experience
with quantum field theory, that
only gives you the
tree-level diagrams.
So if I really write
the bulk path integral,
so Z CFT phi, then, in
the same classical limit,
it can be written
as Z gravity, which
is phi with the right
boundary condition.
And then on the gravity side,
at semi-classical level,
we can actually write down the
path integral for this gravity
partition function.
So that's what we
discussed before.
And then at the leading
order, in performing this path
integral, of
course, you just get
what we have been doing so far.
You just evaluate it at
the classical solutions.
But in principle, you can
also see the fluctuations.
So this is the
fluctuations around, say,
the classical solution, phi c.
And then the action
for the fluctuations
is just given by phi c plus phi.
The minus, of course,
is the classical action.
So we just expand
around the phi c.
So if we expand this,
the leading order
would be quadratic in small phi.
I should now quote small phi.
Maybe let me quote chi, because
that is the same as that phi.
So this chi is the small
fluctuations around the phi c.
So if you expanded this
in chi, the linear order
is 0, because phi c satisfies
the equation of motion.
So this will start in quadratic
order and then cubic order, et
cetera.
So you validated the
quadratic order as a Gaussian.
And then that's the
one-loop diagram.
And then if you go
to higher orders,
then it'll give you
higher-order diagrams.
So if you now include
the fluctuations,
so the SE phi c, which
is a classical action.
This encodes only
tree-level diagrams.
And when you include
the fluctuations, phi,
the fluctuations, chi, and
then this corresponding
to include loops.
So again, the whole
procedure can be captured
by the Feynman diagrams.
So the advantage of
the Feynman diagram
is actually there's a natural
generalization to the loop
diagrams.
And then just include
the loops here.
For example, here, you can
do something like this.
Now you can also have
something like this.
So that's, of course,
one and two, including
the fluctuations, are
under the saddle point,
are including the fluctuation
around the saddle point.
Any questions
regarding this point?
Good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when people draw
these like so-called Witten
diagrams, where they
draw up like this circle.
HONG LIU: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is that
basically what we're doing?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, so let me just
explain one thing.
In the Euclidean, I have been
drawing the ideas like this.
So this is z equal
to 0, et cetera.
So in the Euclidean signature,
as you will do in your PSet,
then this z equal
to infinity, you
can argue is actually
a single point.
So let me just write
down the metric.
So the metric is R
square, z square.
When you go to
Euclidean signature,
you just have dx squared.
So this is a full
Euclidean metric.
So there's something
interesting about the difference
between the Euclidean
and Lorentzian,
even though, from this
picture, it's roughly the same.
So if it's equal to
0, you go to z notch.
And then in the Euclidean
case, you can actually
show that z equal
infinity, even though,
[? naively, ?] you still
have a full Euclidean plane,
but you can argue, actually,
that the whole thing is
actually a point.
And you can roughly see, when
you go to z equals infinity,
the overall factor goes to 0.
So essentially, the whole
space shrinks to a point.
The whole space
shrinks to a point.
So in Euclidean, if
it's equal to infinity,
it's essentially a point.
And then topologically, this
is equivalent to having a disk.
Topologically, the whole
space is just disk.
And the z equal to infinity
is one point on the boundary.
And then the other
is z equal to 0.
And so this is the
interior of the space.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in other words, the
entire perimeter of the circle
is identi--
HONG LIU: It's the boundary.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, this
is the boundary.
Essentially, you can imagine,
each point here is R to d.
Then you add the
point at infinity,
and then it becomes a sphere.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, it
becomes a sphere.
And then the whole thing
becomes like a disk.
So normally, when people
will draw-- so topologically,
you're creating a
disk, just like this.
Then people will just
draw diagrams like this.
Yeah, I draw diagrams like this.
AUDIENCE: If you add a
single point to the boundary,
that single point is equal to
infinity to the boundary, which
is z equals 0?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You mean that you
have a point that [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah, this point turns
out, it can actually
lie on the boundary.
AUDIENCE: But then, on the
boundary, the value of t
is not continuous.
HONG LIU: Hm?
Yeah.
So this is due to the
coordinate choice.
It's just this coordinate
becomes singular at that point.
You can rewrite it.
Yeah, the simplest thing is that
you rewrite these [INAUDIBLE]
coordinates to the coordinate
which has a parameter that has
a boundary really as a sphere.
And then you will see it.
Because when you write
the sphere as a plane,
then this one point
becomes singular.
This is just the standard story.
Just that coordinate
choice is singular.
Any other questions?
Good.
So this is the first remark.
The secondary
remark is that this
is a little bit of an
unusual correlation function.
So this is the bulk
correlation functions,
but with all points
lying on the boundary.
So the counterpart or
just the exact analog
of standard flat-space
correlation functions in AdS--
you can see the end
bulk point and look
at its correlation functions.
So this then will be really just
bring you to the standard QFT
one correlation functions.
Then you have endpoints, z1,
x1, or in the bulk, z2, x2, et
cetera.
And then you just draw a
diagram between them, et cetera.
The area propagator
here would be
just bulk-to-bulk propagator.
There's no boundary-to-bulk
propagator.
propagator just
all bulk-to-bulk propagator.
So this is a complete analog of
your ordinary flat-space Green
functions.
But we can easily imagine that
this correlation function must
be related to those
correlations functions
if you just take those
points to the boundary.
So it's natural to expect, say,
those correlations functions,
since they're at
the boundary, must
be related to those kind
of standard correlation
functions, in which you would
take the point to the boundary.
So those, somehow, in the
end, must be the same.
So if I take those
points to the boundary,
I should recover that guy.
So indeed, this
relation is true.
And you will work it out
yourself in the PSet.
You see, the only
difference is the following.
When you take those points
to the boundary, what you get
is the boundary limit.
So now let's imagine you take
those points to the boundary.
Because here, it's
all bulk propagator.
So those propagator, which
connect to the boundary,
would be the boundary limit
of the bulk propagator.
And then, it just
boils down to, what
is the relation
between the boundary
limit of the bulk
propagator and this boundary
to the bulk propagator?
So the above relation-- let
me just-- I'd rather just
call it a number.
So this star-star-star
just boils
down to the relation
between the k
z, x, x prime, which is our
boundary-to-bulk propagator,
and limit z prime goes to
0, G x, z, x prime, z prime.
So you will find
that these two guys
are proportional to each other.
And once you extract out
that proportional factor,
then you just relate them.
So this is just another
way to calculate.
Because this is the bounty
correlation function.
So this is the boundary
So this is related to the
CFT correlation functions.
And then you can also calculate
the CFT correlation function
just by taking the limit of
the bulk correlation functions.
So this you will work
out a little bit.
Yeah, you will work out the
precise relation in your PSet.
Maybe some of you have
looked at it already.
So any questions on this?
AUDIENCE: What is the
advantage of maybe
using another to express it?
HONG LIU: Yeah, just different
ways of calculating things.
And of course, normally,
I have many different ways
to calculate things.
Some of them may be
convenient this way.
So of them may be convenient
for that purpose, et cetera.
It depends.
Normally, we just
directly are using
the bulk-to-boundary propagator.
If you just do the calculation,
the bulk-to boundary propagator
actually is simpler.
But sometimes, for certain
conceptual questions,
this actually becomes simpler.
So now let's look
at Wilson loops.
So how do you calculate the
Wilson loops using gravity?
So in the gauge
theory-- so I assume
you have already done the
QFT II and the gauge theory?
In the gauge
theory, we also know
it's essentially one of the
most important observables.
The Wilson loop is normally
defined in the following way.
So now I will
explain my notation.
So let me also add
in subscript r here.
So c is a closed path.
So this is defined
for closed paths.
And A mu is a matrix.
So we can see the
[INAUDIBLE] in gauge theory.
A mu is a matrix, writing
the standard away,
in terms of the generator,
in some representations r.
So this is in some
representations.
So this is just the
generators of the gauge
group in some representation,
which we'll call r.
And P is the path ordering.
So in general, you can choose
any representations you want.
But often, we choose r, say,
in fundamental representations.
For example, that's
normally what we do, in QCD,
in fundamental representation.
But you can choose it to
be any representation.
So the physical meaning
of this, so this operator,
by definition, is
gauge invariant,
because of this trace.
And need the path ordering,
because you have a matrix here.
And the matrix, at different
points, don't commute.
So you need to specify ordering.
And so you just specify it
by the order of the path.
And so the physical
meaning of the Wilson loop,
so this is essentially the
phase factor associated
with transporting an
external particle, in a given
representation, say, in r
representation, along c.
So you transport the
particle along some path.
And you come back
to the same point.
Then you find that that
phase does not necessarily
go back to 0.
And so this is a
nontrivial phase.
It essentially tells you there's
a nontrivial gauge field there.
Yeah, so this provides a
probe of the gauge fields.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I know
that people talk
about-- I know that it's
somehow and observable.
But is it actually observable ?
Can you actually
do an experiment
to measure this phase?
HONG LIU: I don't think so.
Ha.
It depends.
Yeah, in some
situations, you can.
Let me mention something
else, then the answer
to this question will be seen.
So the simplest case
would be the W c, just
the single-point function
of W c, say, in a vacuum.
So this is the
simplest observable.
But of course, you can also
consider the generic, say,
a large number, several
[? routes ?] in some general
state, say, for example,
[? finite ?] [? telemetry ?],
et cetera.
So these are the
typical observables.
So now let me emphasize
this external.
So this external
is very important.
So normally, by calling
something external,
we mean that this particle
has infinite mass.
It's infinitely heavy.
And the reason we want
it to be infinitely heavy
is because only for
heavy particles,
in principle, you can
localize the lower path.
Then you can make mathematical
sense of the precise path.
Otherwise, if it's a
fluctuating particle,
then you can not specify a
path-- yeah, ambiguously.
So when we say, an
external particle, I always
say a particle which is assumed
to be infinitely massive.
And also, I've
introduced terminology.
When this r is in the
fundamental representation--
yeah, maybe not right here.
When this r is in the
fundamental representation,
we'll call the corresponding
particle a quark.
If it is in the
fundamental representation,
I will call it a quark.
I will often just consider the
fundamental representation.
In the phase factor, where
we're corresponding to,
you transport a quark.
So one of the very often used
loops is a rectangular loop.
So this is along some
spatial direction,
so this is the time direction.
So let's say the
spatial direction is L,
and the time direction,
using the length,
is T. So imagine you
have a loop like this.
So normally, we can
see that the T, say,
the length of the loop
in the time direction,
is much, much
greater than the L.
So in such a limit,
then, essentially,
you can ignore the
contribution from this side,
from these two short sides.
So in the limit, in which
this T goes to infinity,
to leading order, you can
ignore the short side.
And then you can
think of this loop
when it just has a particle--
so this is a particle moving
forward in time.
This is a particle
going backward in time.
Then you can consider this as
a particle and an anti-particle
moving forward in time.
So in this case, we can
argue, on general grounds,
that this will just,
to leading order,
will give you something iET.
And this e, it just
can be interpreted
as a potential energy between a
single quark and an anti-quark.
So in this example,
this is the same.
In this case, you may be able
to measure this Wilson loop,
because if you can
measure-- experimentally,
you may be able to measure
this energy between the two
particles.
And then, essentially, you can
say, I have measured the loop.
And then you can compare with
the prediction of the loop.
So again, in order to make
this interpretation make sense,
this particle having infinite
energy is very important.
And again, only for the
very heavy particle,
you can really
localize them, and then
talk about the potential energy
between these two particles.
Otherwise, if they
fluctuate a lot,
then it's hard to
make it precise.
So now the question is how do we
calculate this quantity in AdS?
When I don't put an index
here, I just mean that this
the fundamental representation.
The question is how we do that.
So in order to
answer this question,
we first need to
understand how to introduce
a fundamental external particle,
external quark in the N
equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory.
So how to introduce a
fundamental external quark
in the N equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory.
So we know, as we
discussed before,
that everything in the N equals
4 super Yang-Mills theory, so
all fundamental fields,
all the fields in the N
equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory,
they are in a joint
representation.
There's nothing in the
fundamental representation.
Everything is in the
joint representation.
So first we need to introduce
a fundamental object,
an object we transform under
fundamental representation.
After we have done that, then we
need to translate that quantity
to the gravity side.
And then we understand how
the gravity description
of such an external particle.
So this is easy to do.
This is easy to do.
So let's first think about
how to do this in the N
equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory.
And then this is a
very intuitive by using
this [INAUDIBLE] picture.
So we know the N equals
4 super Yang-Mills
theory comes from low-energy
theory of N D3-branes.
They come from the low-energy
So how do we introduce
an external particles?
So now let's imagine,
consider N plus 1 of them,
and let me separate
one from the rest.
So this is still N,
separate one from the rest.
So then there can be open
string connects between them.
So suppose I separate
them by some distance, r,
in the transverse
direction to the D3-brane.
So as we described before, such
as a separation breaks the SU N
plus 1 symmetry of
the D3-brane SU N
and then a single
U1 of this 1-brane.
In particular, such
an open string--
so let's look at the endpoint.
Then the endpoint of this
string can only have indices.
Because this is a
single stream, one
end ending on the other side.
There's only one index.
And here, they can only
have N possible index.
So such a fundamental
string transforms
in the fundamental
representation.
So from the point of view
of this SU N gauge theory,
this is a quark.
So this endpoint is a quark.
So this is a quark.
And the mass of this
quark is equal to-- so let
me call the mass capital
M-- is equal to r,
the length between them divided
by tension of the string.
So this we have derived before.
So this just gives you
the mass of the quark.
So when you separate one
D-brane from the other,
so you have introduced
this quark, with a mass.
So now let's consider that
there's no low-energy limit
[INAUDIBLE].
So in the low-energy
limit of [INAUDIBLE],
so we want to keep this
quark, so there, of course,
you want to take
alpha prime go to 0.
But we want to keep this quark
in the low-energy spectrum,
because we want
this to remain in N
equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory,
because we want to
introduce this particle.
So in this low-energy limit,
when we take off a prime,
go to 0 limit, we also want
to take, at the same time,
r goes to 0 limit, so that this
mass term, r divided by alpha
prime, will remain finite.
Then that means
this will remain,
this particle, such kind of
fundamental representation,
will remain in the N equals
4 super Yang-Mills theory.
Because other modes are massive.
And then when alpha
prime goes to 0 limit,
it goes to infinity.
And under those modes,
we will remain with the N
equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory.
So now let's see what
happens on the gravity side.
So here, you will need to
fill in some details yourself.
I'll only tell you the answer.
On the gravity side, you
have this N D3-brane.
They have one brane which
[? is ?] [? r ?] separated from
this N D3-brane.
And they're separation
is such that, when
you take off alpha
prime and go to 0 limit,
their ratio is finite.
Now, in the gravity
side, you have
to take this so-called
near-horizon limit,
with taking into account.
So what you find in the
gravity side is that,
as before, that N D3-brane now
disappeared into r equal to 0.
Remember, r equal to 0 is that
infinite proper distance away.
And now we are using
this r coordinate.
And when we take
this low limit, we're
using this r coordinate
rather than this z coordinate.
So in that case, you
have i equal infinity.
Then the brane, essentially,
goes to r equal to 0.
which has infinite
proper distance
away from any finite r.
So now this is an
exercise for yourself just
to repeat our previous argument.
Then you will find that
in this regime, when
you take alpha prime
go to 0, this r finite,
this D3-brane does
not disappear.
The single D3-brane
will remain in the AdS.
So the difference, from
our previous story,
is that, in addition
to the AdS, now
you have an additional
D3-brane at some point in S5.
Because D3-brane is in
some transverse direction,
which now become S5.
So you have a D3-brane,
which is parallel
to the boundary coordinates,
but sitting at one point in S5.
And I think this
picture is reasonable,
but you should check yourself.
Because in this regime, this
D3-brane does not go away.
And a remarkable thing
you will check yourself
is that when you take
the [INAUDIBLE] limit,
in this picture,
this is flat-space.
Then you have this formula.
And now, when you take this
limit, this now become AdS.
Now, this AdS at some radius
r, controlled by this r.
And now you can
check one nice thing.
In AdS, if you consider a
string, straight string,
from this D3-brane all
the way to r equal to 0,
which is this
string, this string
has exactly the same mass.
So the mass is equal to r
divided by 2 pi alpha prime--
also in AdS5.
So this is a consistency check.
Because when you take the
low-energy limits, of course,
you should not change the mass.
The mass of the string
will not change.
The only question is whether
it will stay in the spectrum
or will not stay in the
low-energy spectrum.
The mass will not change.
And you will see that
when you take that limit,
you find this
D3-brane remains here.
And this string, which now will
connect some r to r equal to 0,
which is now just some AdS.
This is just some interior
or AdS, infinite proper
distance away.
And then you can
check that, in the AdS
metric, the image of this brane,
viewed from the boundary time--
you have to this ratio
factor, et cetera--
remains exactly equal to this.
So this is an important
self-consistency check,
which I will not do here.
So now, the story
becomes simple.
Now we generate such a string,
such a fundamental particle
with such a mass.
But in order to introduce an
external particle-- in order
to have an external particle
take a mass to go to infinity,
so that means we need to
take r goes to infinity.
So that means we
want to this D3-brane
to lie on the boundary of AdS.
So to summarize, now we want to
move this D3-brane-- in order
for the external
particle, we want
to take M goes to
infinity, then we want
to take r goes to infinity.
So we want this
D3-brane to actually lie
on the boundary of AdS.
So let us just
conclude, summarize.
An external quark
with infinite mass,
in N equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory,
is described by a string
ending on the boundary of AdS.
So this is r equal to infinity.
Because now, we have put in
this D3-brane to the boundary,
and then we'll, of course,
run into a string ending
on the boundary of AdS.
A external quark with
[INAUDIBLE] AdS, of course,
run into a string ending
at boundary of AdS.
And in particular, the
location of the string
can be mapped to the
location of the quark.
So then endpoint of the string
is the location of the quark.
So now we have found a very
nice picture that introduces
a fundamental quark, in N equals
4 super Yang-Mills theory,
because [? what you ?]
[? need  to ?] [? do with ?]
such a string.
And now, when you
do a Wilson loop,
then corresponding to transport
this string around some path,
then endpoint of
the strings runs
on a path in the field theory.
I thought we would stop here.